A political threat looms over much of
the world develops countries as well as
many emerging countries such as in
China's case,
I beginning to see the effects that
demographic aging and it's can any
public services unsustainability can
cause with increasing concern along with
pensions.
Health is another of the fields that
generate the most uncertainties and
fears.
Increasingly aging population and the
emergence of new and expensive medical
technologies have raised some very
important questions.
What would we be able to pay for a
quality healthcare system or when we'd
be condemned to a precarious health
situation that affects our life
prospects?
Is there a successful model that can
lead the way other alternatives?
Well,
in this video we're going to look at a
system that we may more or less like
that which we should definitely know
about us can take into account
throughout this debate.
It's not sort of look at it,
check out the following graph.
It shows the country leaving the third
world's behind and becoming one of the
richest areas on the planet.
Okay?
35 years ago,
Singapore in Spain at the same per
capita income today.
However,
the format more than doubles the Spanish
per capita income in 2015 in Singapore
is per capita income was $86,100 per
year and spends was just $34,750 but
even if we look at countries like
Finland,
Denmark,
Sweden,
Germany,
or the United States as examples,
we'd be able to see that Singapore is
much richer than any of them.
However,
it's often said that Singapore's example
isn't good enough because their wealth
essentially comes from a financial
sector that is much larger than any of
the aforementioned mentions countries,
and that's true,
but it's not the only key to this small
states success.
The weight of Singapore's financial
sector isn't big enough to explain these
differences in par capita income.
In fact,
if we were to eliminate the effects of
these countries,
different financial sector sizes,
Singapore would still be much richer
than the others because it's actually
both trade and manufacturing are more
important in Singapore than the
financial sector.
We're talking about one of the largest
merchandise exporting countries in the
entire world.
For example,
the proportion of electronic material
that this country exports in relation to
its GDP is larger than the proportion of
anything exported by countries like
Spain,
Sweden,
Denmark,
or even Germany.
So the question now becomes,
how did Singapore achieved such a high
level of prosperity?
Well,
if we wanted to simplify it,
we could say that Singapore is the
freest economy in the wells according to
the index of economic freedom published
annually by the Heritage Foundation and
the Wall Street Journal.
It's public spending,
for example,
is half of the u acids and a third of
Sweden's listen to the words of the
historic president's of Singapore Lee
Kuan Yew,
which successfully reflect to the real
foundations of this country's economic
success.
When most of the third world was deeply
suspicious of exploitation by Western
multinational corporations,
Singapore invited them in,
they helped us grow,
brought in technology and knowhow and
raised productivity levels faster than
any alternative strategy could of Lee
Kuan Yew.
Think about what success is,
therefore,
not due to the financial industry,
but due to the same reasons that have
led to the growth of other economies.
Legal security,
low taxes,
monetary stability and moderate
regulations.
Yes
to the free market has made this country
become in many areas.
An example,
and we're not only talking strictly
about economics here,
but also certain social issues such as
health.
When you have that ride,
Singapore is also a role model in terms
of health policy.
Okay,
awesome.
Will Challenge.
Sure.
Let's take a look for example,
at Spain's case,
a country whose health system is
considered one of the most efficient on
the planet.
Well,
the problem is that beyond is me
incorrigible that isn't sustainable.
See,
in just a decade,
the total cost of the Spanish health
system has almost doubles and everything
indicates that as a result of the aging
population and the demand for new and
expensive health technologies,
this trends will be unstoppable and will
continue to worsen year after year.
And don't think that this only happens
in Spain,
not at all.
In fact,
medical bills,
that is the sustainability of health
systems is a widespread problem in other
developed countries.
So the question that arises is how can
we overcome these challenges and ensure
the sustainability of healthcare system
good
model,
which has never taken into account
because perhaps speed that have a
complete the free health system,
a system in which demand and supply on
determines by the market and not in
political offices.
This could lead to some benefits for one
more money for families.
Thanks Steph.
And lower taxes and a precaution re
saving level against any ailments that
may arise that's higher than the present
one.
This would allow for direct primary care
payments and insurance against minor
ailments,
common issues,
and more expensive treatment.
Another
benefit would be a greater diversity of
its competition among different health
centers.
This would mean they'd given the threat
of being displaced in the market,
it's productivity,
differentiation and innovation would be
promoted,
and other words,
we'd achieved a wide range of services
that would positively impact both for
quality of the service and lead to lower
prices.
Cool.
Susan is usually the best formula is in
guarantee better goods and services for
consumers.
Since health gap,
it's not any different.
Okay.
How is it nowadays?
New Country Muses.
All of these principles and to know the
US health care system,
as we'll see,
isn't precisely a free market model.
Now,
there is a country that has used some of
these characteristics since it has done
so with extraordinary results.
So let's consider Singapore's case model
for health reform.
Why now?
Singapore has the best healthcare system
in the world.
It's top quality and costs.
Practically half of that of Spain's
healthcare system and less than a third
of that of the United States isn't just
a matter of lower cost is also above all
about quality and results.
See,
life expectancy at birth in Singapore is
two to three years longer than in
Britain or the United States.
It's infant mortality rate is among the
lowest in the world and just almost half
that of the United States,
Great Britain,
Australia,
Canada,
or France.
Generally it's mortality rates are
impressive compared to most western
countries.
Now,
the question we can ask ourselves here
is how did they achieve such success?
Well,
in this case,
they have achieved at fundamentally by
using market criteria.
First of all,
the main feature of the Singapore model
doesn't just lie in the fact that more
than 60% of all health spending is
private space.
To a large extent,
it is paid directly by users.
That is,
copayments is the norm.
Yeah.
Everyone pays the same.
When they go to a hospital,
there are public and private centers as
well as five levels,
five classes a,
b,
one b two Plus B,
two and c.
Each of these letters gives users a
different service.
For example,
class a gets you a private room and it's
my choice of doctor while in class.
See the dream is shattered and the
doctor is assigned by the hospital.
Of course,
each class has a different cost.
If the user chooses Class A,
they pay for everything.
Instead,
if they choose class,
see the government subsidizes 80% of the
cost,
but where do people get the money to pay
for health care?
Well,
from the same place as in other
countries from the wealth that they
generate from their work.
The difference is that the huge
contributions that government is usually
collect that saved in Singapore in a
mandatory way.
Yes,
citizens have a special accounts where
they keep this money.
They can only use these accounts for
certain purposes such as paying that
pensions,
their children's education for their
home or their health.
In the case of healthcare,
the account is known as medisafe and
does he use to pay for doctors visits,
hospitalizations,
medications,
et Cetera.
This is the second key points of
Singapore's medical system thanks to
this formula of demand is self
regulating and people can manage how to
spend the money they accumulate in these
accounts.
For example,
by accessing different kinds of cow
whether they want to receive or be
hospitalized in hospitals with fewer
comforts but which are cheaper or with
more services and higher costs
decreasing redundant and sip after was
concerned.
Hello?
Very important point is that for most
serious cases there's universal public
insurance which is known as a shield
that it costs only $16 a month for a 30
year old person and with its of course
comes the possibility of hiring other
private insurer.
Is that improve the services?
Only.
The third leg of Singapore's health
system is public expenditure itself.
What happens if someone cannot cover
their medical bills?
Well,
to guarantee access to healthcare,
the government subsidizes hospitals.
Sound has a public funds.
The Metro funds,
which is designed to pay health bills
for lower income family.
Sorry
folks,
this is how it,
Singapore has managed to create a
relatively economical medical system
while achieving results and quality
levels that placed it among the best
health systems in the world according to
the World Health Organization and
different rankings such as Bloomberg's
most efficient healthcare systems.
However,
despite all of this,
when we usually talk about healthcare in
the free market,
we automatically think of the United
States since not Singapore,
which is a serious mistake.
Are you listening?
Oh,
USA versus Singapore?
Oh
yes,
indeed.
The U s does not have a European style
public health system and since the
country results are quite deplorable,
considering that it spends more than 17%
of its GDP on its healthcare system,
which is quite that of most European
countries,
the debate on health,
it seems settled to private health care
is worse than public health care because
it costs twice as much and has similar
or even lower service levels.
But this,
as we saw with Singapore where 60% of
health spending is private simply isn't
true in Singapore.
The health care system isn't any better.
It's one of the best in the world and it
involves much lower costs than in other
developed countries.
Okay.
The issue is that the US healthcare
system isn't only heavily intervenes
upon it and is regulated by the
government.
It's cost is tremendously socialized.
See,
90% of all health spending is channeled
through two different agents other than
the patients how's of every hundred
dollars spent in the US health system?
45 comes from insurance companies,
45 from state programs such as Medicaid
and only 10% from patients' pockets.
Yup.
Public health spending in the United
States is in relative terms higher,
for example,
than in Spain.
But we're going to talk about that in
another video.
The fact is,
as we've seen,
Singapore sets a healthcare system model
on the table that has a great
combination of cost,
innovation,
and medical results.
We may like some aspects of the system
and not others,
but I think it wouldn't be unreasonable
to take it into accounts when talking
about health for future and
sustainability.
So I really hope you enjoyed the video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcasting.
You provided the vocals in this episode
that weren't not mine.
Also,
this channel is possible because of
Patriarchy and our patrons on the
platform of patriarch.
These do you consider joining them and
supporting us in our mission of
providing independent political
coverage?
And as always,
see in the next video
[inaudible].